[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois alexis de dieu le
veut qui va nous parler d'un yvelinois
malheureusement disparu il ya assez
longtemps maintenant qui s'appelle
philippe de dieuleveult
et pour lequel il a auquel il a consacré
un livre voilà alexis de dieuleveult
bonjour aujourd'hui on dit merci d'être
sur notre plateau vous êtes à la fois le
filleul et le neveu de philippe de
dieuleveult
voilà et vous sortez ce livre que vous
qualifiez de récits qui s'intitule
noyade d'état la mort de philippe de
dieuleveult
alors pour les jeunes générations qui
n'aurait pas connu la fameuse émission
la chasse au trésor dont l'animateur
était philippe de dieuleveult
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire en deux
mots de quoi il s'agissait pour
l'émission oui ou non ces missions que
qui était qui est sorti en 81 ch 184
livres et trois ans le concept était
d'avoir un personnage à l'autre bout du
monde philippe habillé de rouge avec son
hélicoptère qui devait chercher des
trésors
depuis des énigmes donc les deux
candidats en studio à paris
les énigmes à résoudre et philippa le
bout du monde devaient suivre les
directives de s'étourdir à utiliser
absolument lieu paris pour retrouver ces
trésors d'accord et c'est une émission
que les messieurs c'est fou qui était
qui passaient tous les dimanches soir
sur antenne 2 et qui a duré donc comme
vous dites 4 en neuf saisons voilà et
donc après qu'est ce qui s'est passé
l'émission s'est arrêtée et philippe a
entrepris une expédition il est
passionné car exactement sensibilisation
africa raft deux mois de préparation
l'objectif c'est traverser l'afrique
d'est en ouest par les fleuves ils sont
partis du lac tanganika donc de
bujumbura burundi pour rejoindre ensuite
l'embouchure l'océan atlantique et elle
reste que c'était pour en faire un
documentaire après où c'était lui dit
avant tout le reporter wyss apportèrent
journaliste lui avait le côté exploits
sportifs qui l'intéressent lesquelles
notre adn devaient absolument
et puis surtout pour lui devait aussi
faire
une émission open émission d'un
reportage un documentaire sur l'allemand
à l'expédition cette expédition solving
alors vous alexis qu'est ce que vous
faites dans la vie n'est pas écrivain je
ne suis pas du tout écrivain noir je
suis je suis fier d'eux qu'une principal
pour la compagnie air france donc je
travaillais les gros porteurs sur le
réseau long courrier
les longs voyages en cabine un métier de
service en tout très bien alors ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que malheureusement
cette expédition africa kraft au zaïre
s'est très mal terminé trois personnes
sont parties dès le début je crois en
trouvons ça trop dangereux trop risquées
ont laissé tomber parce que trop
dangereux sont partis c'est peut-être
une partie de leurs organisations
s'inquiètent deux organisateurs qui ont
vite quitté l'expédition
c'est sur la fin sur la fin
effectivement juste avant la veille du
drame et ya les aventuriers qui ont
décidé de ne pas franchir les fameux
rapides d'inga réputé très très
dangereux est ce que c'est la clé ça
s'arrête en fait tout à coup ils étaient
en liaison quotidienne avec paris il
était à 2 2 comme on appelle ça de rough
trade et tout d'un coup une nouvelle
voie là on est d'accord
donc il reste sept personnes sept
personnes sont parties ce 6 août matin
de l'île aux hippopotames 1981 1985
5 ils sont partis pour franchir les
rapides d'inga qui se trouve devant le
cette fameuse centrale hydroélectrique
d'inga
ce matin là eh ben il se passe quelque
chose et le soir une arrivée au bivouac
et donc la radio n'émet pas le 6 août au
soir ils ont disparu
d'accord vu d'image plus de son
plus d'image il ya deux personnes qui
ont de rescapés qui ne sont pas partis
ce matin là qu'ils ont décidé
d'abandonner devant le danger des
rapides d'accord et eux sont rentrés en
france passant par entrer tout en france
où ils sont restés sur place
oui ils sont restés quelques jours pour
rechercher leurs camarades ils ont
rejoint le barrage d'inga le matin même
ap il a fallu se débrouiller seul et là
ils sont tombés victimes en face à des
militaires et devant toute
l'effervescence et la ji et
ces militaires agité son il s'est passé
quelque chose dont ils ont demandé à
repartir avoir tout de suite ce fleuve
redescendre sur les bords du fleuve et
la refus catégorique on va pas voir le
fleuve on les a mis à l'écart s'il était
question au niveau du barrage d'inga ils
ont été questionnés voulu faire la
maligne celle qui connaît fleuves
européens et surtout qu'ils ont le droit
de signer un papier comme d'avoir il n'a
entendu aucun coup de feu à ce matin ils
l'ont signée revolver sur la tempe
ils n'ont signé alors qu'eux ils en
avaient entendu aucun parce que le bruit
effectivement le rapid rapides sont très
bruyants et en parler dit aussi un
témoignage de témoignages de
d'ingénieurs américains qui eux ont
témoigné de la présence de militaires
ayant droits qui sont mis en place au
bord du fleuve et qui ont mis en joue
les rapts ils n'ont pas entendu le coup
de feu mais ils ont refusé mi terme
étrange où les rapts et les rescapés ont
dû signer un papier comme quoi mais
comme c'est un coup de feu comme vous
dites on les aurait de toutes atteint
pendant du ses coutures c'est probable
ces problèmes ok alors vous fils de jean
de dieu je veux vous témoigner à travers
votre votre papa qui en fait nager parce
qu'en fait on leur a donné une version
aux familles de ces disparus on leur a
dit quoi un accident un accident un
accident et que les sept personnes sont
mortes noyées dans le fleuve
d'accord mais on n'a jamais réussi à
trouver des preuves vraiment
convaincante de cet accident john wayne
non il n'y a pas de sa pauvre sur les
corps donc une noyade pourquoi pas le
lieu s'y prête
mais où sont les corps ou sur les
indices de la noyade de l'accident tous
les indices tous les témoignages
convergent vers autre chose
surtout qu'on retrouve un raft quasiment
intact oui ceux liés à un autre suite
philippe voilà et un autre complètement
détruit tout à fait on pourrait imaginer
avoir cavalcade aidant on pas de tête ou
en tout cas tous les bus d'un disparu
donc voilà ce sont des villageois qui
aurait pris tous les boudins et qu'il
aurait avec l'oreca chez seguin très
bien alors votre père jean voilà qu'est
ce qui les militaires de carrière il est
commandant et n'accepte pas cette
version officielle pas du tout il était
en poste à ryad à ce moment là il
apprend la disparition de son frère
était très proche de philippe d'accord
et il demande à repartir à partir au
zaïre rechercher son frère mener sa
propre enquête tout à fait il arrive sur
place
elle est très mal reçue par le vice
consul de france et par les militaires
donc il avec deux amis il est dérangeant
il est dérangeant sa présence ou une
bête et donc le vice consul de france
lui confisquer tout de suite son
passeport déjà alors qu'il est militaire
officier l'ambassade quand ils sont
passés ça c'est du jamais vu
c'est incompréhensible et 800 du parc de
la thèse officielle qui est de la noyade
votre frère est mort noyé d'accord et
donc on leur propose un corps qui est
complètement inidentifiable est
exactement les gens refusent d'être des
contre monthey a continué mon père que
votre frère est mort noyé lui il dit un
colonel un attaché militaire
je ne croirai à la mort de mon frère que
lorsque je verrai son cadavre à mes
pieds
oui et un cadavre ils ont trouvé un
épuisement qui n'avait pas de tête pas
demain pas de sexe et pas d'extrémité de
pied donc à corps mutilés à 90% et on
vous dit
que ce corps est mort noyé non c'est
comme la très surprenant mais ensuite on
vous dit que c'est philippe qui a été
identifié il ya un télex officiel du
disque consul de france qui est dit
clairement que philippe a été retrouvé
dans le fleuve zaïre et a pu être
identifié d'accord et mon père n'a pas
cru un instant à cette histoire de faux
cadavre devant cette mutilation 90% et
s'est battu pour démontrer la vraie
identité de ce cadavre d'accord donc il
s'est battu pendant 30 ans du fr le
livre retrace surtout les premiers mois
oui je parle voilà mes attentes et ont
laissé de crier sa vérité parce qu'il
n'y a jamais cru statut officiel qui est
toujours en vigueur aujourd'hui d'accord
avec ces stars qui n'est pas acceptable
bien sûr alors imaginons que la vérité
officielle la vraie vérité éclate ça
dérangerait qui aujourd'hui puisque les
les personnes qui étaient au
gouvernement à ce moment là ne sont plus
là pourquoi on va pas dire la vérité ça
dérange janeiro choc à l'époque j'étais
à l'école et il fallait préserver les
liens diplomatiques entre la france le
zaïre comme vous le dite atterrée 1 84
85 aujourd'hui il y encore quelques
personnes impliquées du mois qu'ils
connaissent bien la sphère qui
connaissent bien la vérité qui sont
encore vivants donc de pied tenté des
personnes vivantes
ça peut déranger le ministre ces zones
arranger ailleurs donné le livre il a
répondu alors je lui ai remis au client
le vivre à son de gettings étrangères et
parlement il a lu le livre rapidement
alors que le lendemain soir et m'envoyer
un mail c'est pas vrai absolue mais
qu'est ce que je fais pas ta liste il ne
demande aucune ligne
dans le livre il me remercie pour le
livre et pour les précisions et les
détails qu'on y trouve
c'est dingue bon d'accord
oui c'est une ignominie nous voilà oui
mais ces navires qui dérange mais mais
la vérité se sert jallet les politiques
semblent et les militaires saint père
est officier ça se sait dans le milieu
militaire ça se sait dans le milieu des
services
alors justement les services
philippe faisait partie de la dgse il
était capitaine de réserve mais bon
c'est normalement cette expédition n'est
pas d'accord non ça mon père en est
convaincu philippe était pas là bas pour
une mission d'un canadien n'a que trop
lui ment pas négativement faisait partie
de la réserve opérationnelle du service
action de la dgse de réserve mais à
abolir on croit comprendre qu'il avait
quand même un autre truc à faire secret
pour mon père il y avait autre chose en
parallèle cette expédition et philippe
était pas bien fini par rentrer sur
paris une semaine sur la naissance de sa
fille qui l'a pas connu exactement son
épouse allait accoucher de son troisième
enfant on a monté pour l'accouchement il
n'est pas resté pour cet événement il
est reparti pas bien contrarier et
d'ailleurs et 10 agents au téléphone
c'est pas bon je le sens pas avant mais
il n'en dit pas plus
cissé confirme on perd effectivement et
ses descriptions laquelle il était pas
bien elle était mal préparé les pattes
ambiance y avait pas de il était pas les
axes et expéditions et je pense pas
l'aise avec ce qu'il doit faire en
signant parallèle il avait des choses à
faire à côté qui était certainement pas
cautionné par mobutu ni par la france
qui n'est pas protégé les déranger sa
sécurité n'était pas assurée et
malheureusement il s'est passé ce drame
d'accord alors comment on réagit alors
les autres familles devant tous ces noms
réponse on l'aura tous faire avaler la
même chose ah oui pour tout le foot les
familles ils sont tous membres et
maintenant ben oui songez pas parler à
leur place non non non il est plutôt
discrétion silence a enlacé sorti mon
père qui s'est battu mais bon pour son
frère avant tout bien sûr mais c'est lui
qui monte au créneau et si mon père
s'était pas battu net a refusé ce faux
cadavres qui est une pièce très
importante dans ce dossier aujourd'hui
la sphère serait classé définitivement
avec une noyade accepté par tout le
monde la petite stella la thèse
officielle jana aujourd'hui on irait se
recueillir sur une tombe
quelque part en france fils de dieu le
veut nous ne dirions
il est je pense que seule une petite
poignée de responsables politiques
militaires et civils seraient dans un
secret terrible si vite savoir si en
réalité ce corps inhumés laisserait pas
philippe et surtout qui est un témoin
incroyable c'est un ex agent des
services secrets de mobutu
monsieur je sais pas quoi bébés nés
okito bbb moins soit carrément oui il a
carrément écrit un bouquin j'ai vu
mourir philippe de dieuleveult
tout à fait alors mon père elle
rencontra plus de reprise mais oui qui
voit les photos
absolument on les voit ensemble mon père
était payant convaincus qu'ils disent
est vrai sur certains points à 2 têtes
pas tout parce que quito bébé n'était
certainement pas vraiment sur place le
témoin direct
il avait un poste important et donc été
au courant de ce qui s'était passé
et effectivement mon père en écoutant
cet officier zaïrois avait acquis la
conviction qu'ils disent est vrai sur la
femme sur la façon des élites étaient
décédées et des autres donc cette bavure
militaire iowa ok donc ce récit qui est
passionnant malheureusement vrai donc
très vite mais passionnant bah vous
rendez hommage au combat de votre père
hacker dû prendre une grande partie de
sa vie et bien voir ses amis et surtout
c'est un hommage à martin voyant majeur
une belle vue sur la vie de sentiment
c'est aussi un livre mémoires pour
philippe ne pas les lâcher il était aimé
des français et c'est un livre vérité
pour rendre justice à philippe qui est
victime dans cette histoire avec ses
compagnons vérité écrit cette vérité
pour que soit reconnue officiellement
avec eux cette thèse de la noyade soit
démentie aujourd'hui 35 pas de réponse
de du président mc ren j'évite ont écrit
à l'elysée n'en mesurent une lettre
ouverte adressée non je n'ai devait
juridiquement de lui adresser
il a reçu deux livres d'ailleurs pour
lui pour son épouse et j'ai de retour de
son chef de cabinet donc il transmet
certains statique transmettre mais
demande au ministère accord je demande
au président de se positionner lui
personnellement je comprends mieux pas
se cacher derrière les ministres j'ai
cette affaire mais aussi au courant et
donc bravo pour ce récit ce témoignage
qui est vraiment très passionnant et
émouvant m'a bien servi à les relever
à bientôt j'espère un plaisir
[Musique]